ma numero non ricordo sono le ore 7 77
nostri desideri del mattino
probabilmente già realizzato che cosa è
successo dyson avendo visto rinnovata
passione per la pulizia da guglielmo non
era così prima comunque notato stato uno
scapolo d'oro ma mia è favoloso ragazzi
sposate lo quindi ci siamo sentiti con i
ragazzi di dyson di nascosto per
organizzare una sorpresa il cui elmo che
cosa hanno fatto loro non ho deciso di
fare molto di più e hanno sposato una
puntata del blog mas
ma c'è di più ci hanno mandato questo e
adesso andiamo a vedere come reagirà
elmo di fronte a una gioia direi nella
gioia buongiorno di ignorare il gusto di
lopapa di non ignorarci c'è una sorpresa
governo dai non ci credo non si che come
bene andiamo ma è quello che ci ha più
bello della mia vita culto sei stato
rimpiazzato per dormire è un blog è un
blog in collaborazione con l'ice di
dyson ha visto la tua rinnovata passione
per la polizia non parlare di tutte
queste cose senza sentirmi vero un'idea
pazzesca oggi pubblicherò chiunque
mettere a posto tutto grazie di cuore
dyson non ce la facevo più da ci va bene
del tuo canale ma io sto ringraziando
delle persone grazie non ce la facevo
più
e poi quella che bel colore ai perché lo
guida del gubbio si elettrico tipo a
svegliarli ragazze
ospitanti svegliati con dvd scorse
puntate cosa che deve fare
[Musica]
riunione il signore subito farsi
traumatico e poi la colazione ragazzi
alla pizza è che però hanno sul legno
come bruciando tutto parte volevo
rifiutare la direttamente nello stomaco
un assaggino se incappato è faccio una
fredda e parlano a breve ma se il babbo
natale colore di spaghettata che dicono
mamma natale mai grande gianmarco
l'imprenditore romano pane banana breve
è un pan alla banana dolce demon plum
cake alla banana al cioccolato e le
mandorle faccio il suo bari ma vai a
cagare dove diciamo è tanto mica per voi
e per il capo lo mangio solo cui thelma
ma per conoscere già ok diciamo genere
mai accusare di cronista
oggi cambia la solfa nel vostro migliore
amico perché metterete tutto quanto in
ordine oggi facciamo una challenge
pazzesca challenge dell'ordine aironi
compito secondo oggi c'è un nuovo
inquilino lui questo qui è io direi io
me lo devo studiare lì mentre perde il
tempo per studiare molto meravigliosa
per fa volare per adesso visivamente mi
piace molto lo attaccherà in camera come
fosse una chitarra nostro invece di
appenderlo dovrebbero utilizzare una
chitarra che invece guarda di suonare
suona si sono sempre questo pulsante 23
suoni diversi
come vedete una funzione lei
ve la spiego dopo è proprio tipo un po
la regina ei vertici dedicate sac in due
secondi l'ha attaccata sentite questa
qui mela riuscite a nuove capacità di
insinuarsi senza rovinare lui è un
guanto la patente dopo questo bomba
dedicati detto delicatissima esatto a
questo punto ma lamentare cosa ti sei
scordato un pezzo noti secondi la
accorciamo i divani ceca la casacca alla
kakà a casa cos'è che la cuccia qui dei
gatti dei cani tutti sul chi paga non
voglio vedere un pelo in giro passiamo a
lei che può aspirare delle briciole ma
può anche spolverare che vi direte che
modo poter utilizzare questo strumento
seguite facendo ma conciata così
fateci sapere se vi piace il nuovo look
arrivare in pieno pettinari 40 distrarre
il ragazzo le tue passioni
detto ciò prigione questo qua per la mia
esperienza lo preferisco fare una cosa
che sanno da rita seguirli quanta
polvere si annida qua qua qua qua ma
soprattutto cambio in modalità boost
tastiera del computer
torna a casa mia diletta ultimo
accessorio faccio vedere anche se ci
sono altri dai torchi come come con
melis cusmai stop ai talk devi toccarti
con budget line torto di non specialisti
nel settore si è così a questo punto in
due seconda tac tac monti super super
veloce ai talk attacchiamo tutto questo
era quello di prima segretissimo questo
qui è più intelligente a seconda della
superficie ampia la forza di aspirazione
poiché vi chiedo per questo momento è
chiudere gli occhi aprire gli orecchi
sentito il suono
alzato il livello di aspirazione perché
ha capito da solo questo nostri lunedì e
lo so il mediano sempre stregonesca di
tutte abbiamo finito di lavorare questo
caso è già pieno di disappunto un botto
da roba se togliamo questo seguitemi per
l'ultima magia
apriamo stack fatto chiusano motivazioni
l'altro anche io voglio fare il tac però
non voglio vedere il robot non li vedrà
in giro che il cammino dalla grazia
ragazzi ciao ragazzi tutto bene ma se
scusare aspettiamo che finisce il bimbo
è appena un fascicolo di nova tutto al
membro tengo a faccia avuto a fare
quindi io direi invece che finisce nelle
ceriana e mentre quello va in giro noi
portiamo in due sacchi facciamo quita
che abbiamo fatto tutto
senti questo smr raga ok enrico questi
qua mi fai colorati gabriele grazie
mille nel mio dei moderati ma grazie a
correre fatto rumore che ha fatto cose
ma scusatemi ed ai truck agata con
cappellone ragazzi sarà divertente
perché questo stampa molliccio non
sostituirsi a banana angelina jolie
motivi per favore bandar e gionata da
questo canale battute sono veramente
facci vedere la maestria ma tira fuori
tutta la tela legno della cucina con
ritardi appena adesso chiamo incantesimi
però po d'acqua sicuramente c'è che
retini sarà bagnato non ho neanche gli
stecchini per verificare
by diego e abbatte finito dai party ne
vediamo se si è mai chiesto cosa bisogna
scherziamo vediamo quando sarà bello ma
va ai controllato che torna nella teglia
che il prodotto a detta dei tappi
attaccate di gatto è un capolavoro da
capo dicono che sembra una cacata sopra
una lettiera giudica la sua faccia e di
vino possono avere una fetta di oppure
dietro
grazie mentre qui c'è proprio
cucciolandia guardate guardate la
perfezione di questo trio che non
diventerà mai un 2 o 3 stelle comunque è
arrivato il mio momento
allora eccoci qua vabbè vabbè no no va
bene e cioè un breve lilly futuro in
mano il sistema delle ruote sono tipo
cingolati mi che non carichiamo l'app
dyson links creiamoci mettiamoci al wifi
netti di gas
[Musica]
a questo tool e il doc nuova
famose pulizia è legato che aveva tutta
sta roba
vale allora ha dominato sentiamo vistoso
marta fede è famosa cotto la merenda
scattata processo era un tappeto
spuntati da non ci credo che la crisi si
è mai stato a sistemare è partita la
challenge vediamo 25.024 mamma mia
guarda la challenger questa gente qui si
vabbè ma secondo uno sborone cioè che
mai sono charlie in cui sei bravo ma non
c'è ormai arriva un poeta strato mai
fatto in vita minias hanno due modi non
la devo dire così a me l'appoggio così
dare le gambe oppure vai soltanto di
braccia bonucci come preferisci e tu sei
braccia solo di spalla da tre anni
ok no quella che portò con che calcola
cazzi felicissimo evidente liscissimo è
mi è venuta un'idea se cercate un mezzo
via
[Musica]
ognuno è avere la stessa tra parla
perché sennò l'attrice differenze
quando dava
[Musica]
all'uscita
dietro svantaggiate
[Musica]
bari privato
almeno migliore amico adesso sta qua che
sta facendo un riposino
se nella cui cerca pulita bravissimo
ceco si è poi vedere ma che ci fa la
chetta il bel in mezzo al corridoio in
piedi ma il delirio uscì per terra che
non ha visto l'ingresso quindi non ho
visto l'ingresso raga ragazzi ma che
avete fatto
enrico lo diciamo che è scappata un po
più la valvole pulizie manuale telecom
butta la spazzatura va beh scusate ma
che ci fa il sacco di gabetto cose fatte
sono i sacchi ho fatto con grande
assente da casa con la fila polvere
tutto l'iter e pavimento loculi do tutto
e mi ha fatto l'in piani di scivolo dove
è domanda butta tutto io adesso si
risolve un po dopo 19 6 mutu è arrivato
il momento della verità ea guardare il
cioccolato alla dignità dei brand della
stella la nostra strada
no io lo mangi
di fatto passare al plagio nei confronti
di john marcolini capelli progetto che
più che non ti piace non ti farai mai
questo torto devo assaggiare per certo
non me l'ha perdonata romagna riceveva
no non è paolo di più
dopo un po a una 3 n anche se non vedo è
venuto per i momenti di silenzio che
aspetti soltanto il primo gli aspetti
arriva alla fine perché se la guzza dopo
aver mandato a forza i ragazzi a finire
di fare quello che non ho mai iniziato a
fare questo punto sei arrivato il
momento di fare una piccola recensione
sulle prime impressioni del threesixty
euris la guardate quante cane nero
anzitutto grazie tyson che grazie alla
fine per aver chiuso questa
collaborazione me insaputa devo dire che
è facilissimo premi play e aspira tutto
quanto alla modalità super silenziosa
che manco lo sempre la ri forte è quella
fortissima che quindi era proprio a
spirare qualsiasi cosa di oltre due
secondi intuitivo creato calendario per
cui lunedì mercoledì venerdì e sabato
sono gli stessi giorni nei quali noi
andiamo in onda
social viola le 19 lui si sveglia la
mattina alle 10 e pulisce tutto quanto e
poi alla fine mappatura di tutto quello
che ha pulito cioè è geniale darò altri
giorni per poterlo testare ma secondo me
è quello in combo colpo 11 ciao io
regina nel pulito catena con una scelta
ci hanno già a domani alle 14